so all right uh today i'm going to do a
lecture on insane in the end game
and uh i wanted to focus on a couple
really really complicated end games
uh that i saw played
by some of the top players like really
really really complex
and i want to kind of illustrate how you
break them down to understand them
because trying to
play a really really complicated end
game
without being able to simplify it
without being able to
you know figure out what's going on more
simply it's just really hard because
like
it can be overwhelming to figure out
everything but you have to be able to
first of all you
have to have some basic knowledge a lot
of the time you have to calculate
quite a bit uh but a lot of it also
comes down to just
kind of breaking it down into bite-size
pieces and then figuring out what you
have to do
um so let's start with that um
so we're going to start with this game
this is from uh aneesh giri
against jan nipponshi at the canadas
tournament which
started this year uh for those of you
know
for those of you who know um obviously
it got halted so who knows what's gonna
even happen to it when it's gonna get
resumed if it is
so but in any case we're going to check
this out and see what's going on
uh so again uh this position is kind of
an interesting one
uh this one's actually white to play so
it's a niche to play
and he has to make the decision of
what the best decision is and first of
all can he take the pawn on
c4 so i'm going to give you guys a
couple minutes i'm watching the youtube
chat right now
so hello everyone and if you have some
suggestions feel free to say them in the
chat
or if you have particular questions
about the position as well
but in this case we're actually
discovering whether white should play
bishop takes c4
uh whether that's a good move and if it
isn't then
maybe an alternative that would be
decent for white
um so the target audience like i'm not
really targeting a very specific rating
wage but i would say this is definitely
a more advanced lecture
um at least like what we're going over
is extremely complicated i'm going to
try to break it down
so i don't want to say that if you're a
beginning player you can't watch or
anything like that but i would say it's
definitely targeted more towards
advanced players
so if you think bishop takes c4 is a
good move that's quite reasonable but
you have to ask yourself like
is there just no problem with it is it
just a free pawn
uh because obviously white would love to
take this pawn um
the question is whether black has any
resources after you do
no problem says
so what do you guys think after bishop
takes c4 what could happen
right like it looks at first like very
safe right
because if takes of course you could
take with the queen of rook you can only
be better there with outside past pawn
probably
uh and if i don't take you're
threatening bishop takes bishop check
so i can't don't have time for a move
like rook c8 because you simply take the
bishop with check
so keep in mind we're looking at it from
black's point of view so this is c4 not
f4
and this is c8 not f1 uh but yeah
it looks like it's just a very very safe
move right
um but it turns out there's actually
something very very dangerous for black
after you take so probably believe it or
not here white should probably play
something like rook h4 just improving
the rook
so you're kind of keeping an eye on this
pawn maybe you're gonna try pushing your
a pawn to try to distract
i would say that black's maybe a bit
better like after a move like rook c8
just trying to put pieces behind and
support this pawn
but it's still a very complicated
position i would say that this is not by
any means easy to win the queen's hard
to dislodge
and the black king's always open um
but white did in fact take the pawn but
the question is what did
napolmishi as black have in store what
was his plan because it looks at first
like this is a completely safe pawn to
take
but what is black's plan here
okay so you guys are getting it the idea
is that rather than play
bishop takes bishop first you start with
king g7
and this is a really cool move because
you're getting out of the pin but also
somehow
white has problems breaking this pin it
looks like white has a whole move
to break the pin right and then
you know it should be just good right
like if you could just play queen b3
queen b4 you break the pin
life is good but it turns out it's
actually extremely difficult to do so
first and of course you have to try
right if you allow this and takes you're
just going to be lost
so in the game queen b3 was played which
is one of the two reasonable options
but the other one was queen before
and i realized we haven't this is almost
more of a middle game than an end game
so far but i kind of want to show how
the end game was reached because it was
really fascinating this whole phase of
the game
and i feel like just because it's an end
game class doesn't mean i have to stick
to it but it's insane so it takes
one of the titles it's insane even if
it's not quite an endgame yet
so rook b8 is definitely uh the most
logical choice and then this is the
problem the queen somehow doesn't have
any squares
um like it can try to go to a4 but then
you have all sorts of issues involving
rookie check and then going after this
rook it's um
not queen with queen c6 of course but
like all of a sudden you just get like
viciously attacked
like you can check you can play here you
have bishop f5 type moves all of a
sudden you're just getting wrecked right
so the only real try here is actually to
play this
um and then here the question is how to
proceed now because this is actually a
surprisingly annoying move you're
blocking the rook from coming in
and you're ready to support the bishop
with this pawn
you've seen this pitch i may have given
a lecture on this before but it was
probably
like i don't remember it honestly when
you give lots of lectures you end up
recycling some material
but i definitely don't give the exact
same lecture almost ever so it's usually
like i probably gave it about a specific
position in this game
um but yeah i mean when you give lots of
lectures almost everyone recycles at
least a little bit of material
um but anyway bishop b5 so the question
is what to do with black here bishop
takes a2 by the way is not a terrible
move here
um but it's it's one pawn right and then
after that white maybe has the
opportunity to regroup a little bit
so the question is can we do something
more forceful here
queen b7 is not exactly a fork because
this is defended right so i do have the
opportunity maybe to play a4
and try to defend if you try that so you
have to be a little bit careful about
that
and again i'm seeing lots of individual
moves bishop d7 queen c1
rook c8 right but it's better if i see
an idea that you have or maybe a whole
variation
i had this problem when i was doing a
lecture today
i was teaching a group of kids on zoom
and it was
every time i would ask for a variation
they would i'd see like a bunch of
single moves in the chat
and it's like uh you know an individual
move is nice right but in most positions
you you
want to plan it out like this is not
like queen b7 and white resigns right so
you want to have a deeper idea you want
to look farther ahead in the position
so it's nice when i see things like rook
c8 with some bishop h3 idea something
like that
but rook h3 like i think the white just
has too many possible responses you want
to look for your more forcing moves
first right if you give white an
opportunity to do this it's going to be
very very difficult to actually give
checkmate
so like if rook c8 here for instance and
we play
maybe rookie maybe even rookie one at
first or even just this move with the
idea of this
i think checkmate is going to be very
difficult
so i see some suggestion with this but
keep in mind i can block with the rook
right
blocking with the rook is not illegal
and might be a decent choice
no
also keep in mind that if you leave with
the queen i have this check which might
prove to be very very nasty
so you have to be a little bit careful
here
yeah this is very complicated by the way
you might need a little extra time like
this is uh as i said this is a really
complicated game
and again it's it's a difficult thing um
even for like strong grandmasters to
figure out
so it's not about whether we can figure
out everything it's just about
challenging ourselves to
to discover these moves because again
like when i followed this game live i
was trying to figure all this out and it
was so complicated
um and even analyzing the game
afterwards and spending time at the
board like it was very difficult
uh but the key is more to challenge
ourselves to come up with good ideas and
maybe
come up with some good lines see what we
can do
yeah i mean rook takes b5 queen takes b5
everything is on light squares but you
still need a follow-up right you still
need
a tactic and the fact is that after
takes takes i still have my king to go
to g2 if you try to check me
it's hard to get this pin in with the
rook queen covering so it's just very
difficult
but i would say that the key is move
order
so deutsche valuations kind of has it
an idea with this and then trying to
take but the problem is if you try that
the bishop's not supported on d3
so even if i move backwards rook takes
b5 doesn't really work
not to mention i think i can play here
and then i cover the squeeze square
so that's going to make your life at
least a little bit harder if you try to
attack my bishop i can always defend
with a4
at the very least i don't see the wind
there
so you have a ver you're very close to
the correct uh idea
so you have this followed by rook takes
b5 and queen c1 but the problem is after
check here my king can escape
right so if you try to do something like
this
you don't actually have a follow-up and
now your own king's gonna get attacked
and you're down
on exchange so once again guys this is
really complicated stuff
let's see what we can do
so queen b7 was mentioned but the
problem generally is this move a4 comes
into play
which is just a really really nasty move
and guys uh just to keep in mind like um
i definitely like full suggestions
meaning variations and different ideas
but again this is complicated stuff
you don't want to feel like all right
well i probably i might be wrong with my
variation
i shouldn't suggest that i kind of end
up saying this most lectures but it's
like
i'm wrong all the time and most players
are as well but
oftentimes you can learn a lot when you
suggest a line even if it's incorrect
so f5 has been mentioned but this is
also a very loose move
and as we've discussed the rook doesn't
mind going backwards the rook on e1 is
actually quite solid
and then a4 comes and again once you're
solid uh ah
you're correct though i can't go back
right because of this this this is
this is true so after f5 i need i'd need
another move maybe i have to go to h4
um yeah i'm glad i caught myself there
that would have been embarrassing
but yeah i think i go to h4 and somehow
my rook on h4 might be better than on e4
because again i can still do this i
don't think you checkmate me here
if you try to give checks definitely
very scary though
f5 is definitely a scary idea ah maybe
if f5 i block
this way actually this might be it
because now if rook takes b5 like i
block your check
so this might actually be a little safer
come to think of it
but again lots of really dangerous ideas
uh oh even here there's this oops sorry
even here there's this move right
threatening this and this
maybe this is also bad
yeah this doesn't look good yeah i have
to be careful uh there's still this
and then it takes there's checks but i
don't know if i'm actually gonna give
perpetual there
i might like here takes
check i'm not sure if here then check
probably you escape though i think
because you have extra material you
should be able to run like this
so this probably also doesn't work maybe
you have to go here then
just to cover this mate uh and to cover
this square as well
but yeah f5 is also very very dangerous
move so that's a good suggestion
um
the queen can fork the rook and give
check on e7
ah so you want to play here and then e4
for black so you're cutting off
communication and doing this the problem
is yeah
the queen can give a check here for
example and that might um
you know make your plans not so great
there's also moves like a4
of course um but again guys this is
really complicated the correct idea is
actually bishop d5
um and again this is something i checked
later but as you can see it's not like i
can work out all the variations it's
very complicated so
like f5 for example was not a move that
i had looked at and it looks at least
very dangerous to me
although rook h4 maybe it doesn't work
but apparently this is the correct idea
so the main idea of course is if rookie
won you simply to grab this bishop with
the idea of this check
so white has to play rookie 2 here
and then here there's a really
remarkable idea
to try to win this game it's actually
really something
yeah and bishop d7 by the way uh soviet
dog is almost always runs into a4 and i
don't mind this exchange really
uh a4 is one of those moves that you
really want to prevent unless you have a
specific counter to it because a4 really
solidifies white's position
queen b7 is definitely the start but the
question is what happens now white
probably has to give this check
uh to try to get counter play
and here you can go to h8 you can go to
f8 it's actually very very complicated
uh f8 is the simpler the one though
um and now you have a couple ideas so
white can try to attack the f
pawn but you have a really really cool
idea
against this side against this move
king h8 actually then queen f5 might be
the best defense trying to take here but
in this particular position you have a
really really cool move that
actually ends the game almost
immediately
this is like very unexpected
queen c1 queen h6 instead of queen b7
queen c1 queen h6 but again i i think
you're allowing this
check it at least looks dangerous like
this looks
pretty dangerous to me so i mean
obviously allowing that would be tough
but maybe i can play here guarding this
uh to me this doesn't look that clear um
so queen b7 i believe is the better move
and then after queen g4 king f8
so a4 is kind of the the best try but
queen f5 there's kind of a cool
refutation too i want to give you guys
the chance to find it
bishop g2 and queen f3 but i don't know
if you want to trade queens actually i
think that then the a pawn becomes a
little bit stronger
uh and my rook can run here so you don't
actually win any material
very nice great wolf bishop f7 uh ah
envy me also find it found it yeah um
this is quite a move because it
basically stops this from being check
and the idea is that you're attac you're
having a really nasty double attack
so this is just super super strong
um kind of a cool little thing
so a4 is a better defense
and now what is the idea
so bishop f3 is actually okay uh
as an idea but you actually have a more
clever way to do it
which is by playing bishop c4
so you're threatening mate and you're
threatening the rook this is kind of a
really cool tactic but the idea is that
you because you're threatening this mate
white has to play a more passive move if
you play a move like this it's playable
but then you have to deal with queen e6
you have to deal with queen here
um there are all these active moves that
white can try whereas after this
uh white has to play a more passive move
like for example king g1 and then you
take the rook so you kind of get a
better version
um by doing it this way first but bishop
c4 is kind of a cool move right so
you're threatening the rook and you're
taking advantage of the fact that this
is a matron
so very cool uh but anyway i just wanted
to show these variations because to me
they were really fascinating uh but as
you can tell they're so complicated so
for
even a very strong per people like
napomnishi and geary
to find them is very very difficult i'm
curious how much of them they saw
and the funny thing is after bishop c4
it's not like the end of the game it's
just you win in exchange and then the
game continues
but probably it should be a technical
win up the exchange
so in the game queen b3 was played rook
b8 happened anyway
and gary decided to sacrifice um
to the queen for a rook and bishop
and this is a very very common technique
in order to try to get a draw by a
fortress
and fortresses are a very very complex
thing so this is what happened in the
game he threw in his check
um and then took first i should mention
that after check here
check here this is actually very
important
taking this queen does not work because
you have this check and then taking the
rook
so there was no attempt like that so he
simply took and yeah i mean you have
these fortresses and it's essentially an
attempt to draw the game by basically
creating a barrier or your opponent
can't cross
or creating a position where they simply
have no winning ideas
but i would say fortresses are one of
the most complicated things
it's funny magnus carlsen had a quote
where he said i don't believe in
fortresses which is obviously facetious
because fortresses exist
and he knows it uh but it's more kind of
a comment that
fortresses are so difficult that if you
have a lot of material on the board to
actually create a fortress is so
so tricky
someone's asking if i would have played
something like this myself i would say
that
my judgment call here would be that a
fortress would be extremely difficult so
i would look to avoid it
but i also thought that after rook b8 i
don't think white has better
so i think that this is actually a
really interesting drawing attempt
because you're so close to having a
fortress
but i'm not quite sure you do and the
way napoleon she played this position
was absolutely incredible
just it's one of those things where you
look at it afterwards you even look at
it with table based a little bit
uh but mostly i just analyzed it on my
own but uh
even when you look at it with tableways
it's amazing accuracy and he never
spoiled the win which is
quite incredible in a position like this
but i would say that this is still very
close to the draw the a pawn matters a
little in that it
creates a secure square for the bishop
but overall
it's just very very hard when you're
just left with queen and pawns on the
same side to win
against the rook and peace because the
rook and peace covers so many squares
even if you're up a pawn oftentimes you
just can't win
um and again like you can't really
uh blame gary for going for this right
like he's trying to survive he's trying
to defend he's had a bad position
but i would say that he you know i don't
know how optimistic he was about drawing
this position but i would say that it's
a very difficult draw
but the key question here is
what is black's plan when you have a
position like this where you're trying
to crack a fortress
it's really important to have a plan now
sometimes you can probe
meaning that you kind of make little
threats you kind of see what your
opponent's up to you don't have to be in
a rush i like this kind of way of
playing
but i would say to crack a fortress you
need a plan
so i what i want to ask you guys here
and i'll give you a minute or two
because it's a complicated position
what is your plan for cracking this
fortress
first of all what how is white going to
set up this barrier number one
and number two what is the plan for
cracking this fortress i think it's
extremely important to have a plan now
you might have to change your plan you
might have to alter what you want to do
later
based on what your opponent does but you
definitely need a plan in order to win
this game
so take your time and try to find a nice
plan for black
ah that's interesting gonna be me yeah i
mean i'm not sure
i'm not sure i remember it but i'm sure
i've seen the game
ah the armageddon yeah the armageddon
though was a very simple fortress that
he created right with the rook moving
back and forth like even without the
bishop it would have been a fortress so
that was a very simple one
or without a bishop it would have been
close to a fortress at the very least
so getting the king off the eighth is
not a plan but i would say it's a good
idea right like you don't want this king
on the eighth you want to move it up the
board somehow
um but yeah white has everything
protected it's not an easy
thing so you definitely want to activate
the black king that's part of it
but what is your plan as far as cracking
the fortress that's a little deeper
right
you definitely want to use the pawns to
shield from the rook tracks it's hard
for the rook to give checks indefinitely
though especially with this many pawns
and the rook only has a few squares that
are always safe
it's different if the rook has like a
whole sheath of squares where
it can never be attacked or something
like that then it can be really nasty
but
at least at the moment the queen can
guard enough squares that you shouldn't
be able to perpetual with the rogue
i agree with soviet dog's plan though
you want to use your pawns to crack at
white's pawns now you have to be careful
the more pawns you exchange the closer
you get to a position which is probably
drawn
but you're gonna need to use your pawns
to get rid of these with
white has these pawns the king is so
safe
and believe it or not even though it's
you just have a queen you're actually
playing for an attack or a checkmate now
you're not necessarily trying to mate
you're trying to create mating threats
or create severe threats so that your
opponent has to pitch material
but the main idea i think in this
position
is you want to move your pawns up the
board and be able to crack at your
opponents
uh to crack your opponent's pawns you
also have to move the king up
and again in most of these positions not
being in a rush is very important
especially if your opponent has no real
plan
the key when you're facing a fortress is
you want to think about
you want to think about um patience
because
they're not really doing anything right
they're just sitting so it means that
you want to improve your pieces to the
absolute max before you try to do
anything
there are times when they have to set up
their fortress so you have to actually
beat them to it
but for the most part when they set up a
fortress or try to they're not doing
anything they're just sitting
so you want to improve every single one
of your pieces before you try to crack
at it
and that's kind of a good rule of thumb
to follow right because you have all the
time in the world to
improve your pieces if you try to do
something before doing that you're going
to run into trouble
so let's see what he did he played queen
c1 check
threw a check on c6 and again this part
i'm skipping over a little just because
not to skip over it but more that black
has several options on how to push and
how to check
there isn't just one good option but i
would say that he puts the queen here on
purpose to make sure this bishop doesn't
have a chance maybe to improve itself at
some point
he wants to make sure the bishop kind of
stays here it looks nice but it's also
not doing a whole lot
so he wants to make sure the bishop
can't reposition itself
so king goes back also he's controlling
this diagonal which comes sometimes is
important as well
and now he plays h5 so he calculates
that these checks don't really lead
anywhere
uh white plays them anyway because there
isn't much else to do
and then tries to attack this pawn
so black plays queen f3 to defend it
rook h8 and then this is a really
important moment um because it kind of
defines
like how the game gets played from now
on so what does black do now how does
black make progress from here
white's basically putting the rook here
to make sure nobody you're not going to
open up my king with the move h4
so this is quite normal for anish
to try to prevent this idea so the
question is what can napoleon should do
as black
so i see e4 i see f5 and e4
you have to be careful about moves like
f5 and the reason i say that is because
then your king
is a little bit more exposed so if i
start kind of you know
going here say king here maybe even this
and i start checking your king
your king might have to go to some
unpleasant square to avoid checks
and you want to be careful of that so
i'm not saying f5 is a poor move
but i'm saying that you have to be very
very careful with moves like this
if you play f5 at the wrong moment it
can be very very bad for your king
so a lot of you are suggesting e4 and
that's a very very logical suggestion
but the key is
what is the variation after e4
what is white going to do
indeed it is david indeed it is this end
game was
incredibly complicated
so after e4 rook here i agree with you i
think the move h4 would be excellent
this is one of the main breaks you want
to try to get in because after pawn
takes then all of a sudden you have two
pawns running up the board and those
will be very dangerous to white's king
again keep in mind the main thing is you
want to be able to threaten white's king
if you can make white's king feel
uncomfortable that's when you're going
to be able to make progress or force
white to pitch more
material nippo did win this eventually
yes that is correct
for those of you very savvy you can see
the little one in the little zero
and again i didn't mean to relieve any
suspense for you guys but again i mean
mainly this is about the analysis right
we're not like
who's gonna win but yeah rook d8 and
bishop d1 exactly deutsche evaluations
so after e4 rook d8 check king e7 you
still have the move bishop d1
and this is a really really clever
defense so the question is what does
black do now
uh thank you uh muammar
sorry about the pronunciation
so f5 is not a great suggestion here
because your queen is hanging i assume
you met at a later point
[Music]
queen a3 is possible but typically you
want to be able to control more central
squares like this pawn
is not necessarily the most important
part of the position here uh the king
side is really where the battle is going
to be won or lost
this is one of those things that happens
in like fortress type positions or end
games you find that outside pawns
they often don't matter as much as they
do in other situations because the pawn
can never really move you're just gonna
take it
so the pawn is actually not the most
relevant part of the position you wanna
be more centralized
so queen five is possible but it's also
a little awkward right
so after a move like this for instance
um
maybe even rook d2 is possible with the
idea that on e3 we have this
and again it's just a little bit
annoying right like our queen
feels like it's in the way here
so very good chess king queen c3 so the
queen here is pretty nice because it
prevents the rook from retreating to
these squares
it threatens queenie one check so the
rook can't go here so it pretty much
forces white's reply of rook d4 rook t5
and i'm sure if you've seen any of my
lectures and probably on most people's
lectures you talk about how
forcing moves are very important in the
endgame sometimes they're less important
but i would say they still have a degree
of importance and
one of the crucial things is that you
always look for your most forcing move
and
queen c3 was extremely forcing because
it takes away these squares and
threatens the check
so it forces white's reply white only
has one reply
and oftentimes that means that this move
should be examined
uh right away but he had a planned
follow-up he didn't just do this to and
then rook d5 and was like
now what what was his plan that was the
key
all of my lectures wow that's quite a
few
at this point i've been giving chess
lectures for oh my goodness
too many years all right queen a1 is
possible but it doesn't really
keep in mind you're trying to go after
this pawn but i don't care about that
pawn that much
so if you play here i don't want to say
i don't care about it at all but it's
not really the most important part of
the position in my mind
so here i could think about rook d2 but
even a move like kg2 i would think about
with the idea that on queen takes pawn i
go here and we're just
you're kind of reducing too much
material an example of something that
could happen would be if you try e3
which looks very strong i play rook f5
and somehow
you might actually have a problem here
because if you play e2 i'll simply grab
that guy put my rook here and this is an
example of a position
which is a fortress because my rook can
move back and forth my king can move
back and forth all day
you simply cannot run me out of moves
here and
the king cannot progress past this rank
past the fourth past the fifth
so you see how even though you've won a
piece you still can't win because of the
idea of a fortress
so this is actually an example of how
things can go wrong for you
because that looks so promising once you
play e3 but at least from
what i've seen as long as white achieves
this you actually can't win
so that's why these positions are so
complicated but i'd say that you should
lean towards
playing more centrally or playing more
particularly against white's king
this pawn or going after this pawn is
just not worth
the tempo it the tempe it costs
this pawn does not play a big role
whereas the white king
the discoordinated edition of white's
pieces remember how i said
patience was super important and
fortresses when you have your opponent's
pieces on bad squares
when their king's not on the perfect
square the king would like to maybe move
up
that's when you actually should be less
patient that's when you should think
about striking
e3 here is definitely a move but you
have to be very careful you're leaving
yourself with these two pawns so after
pawn takes pawn i'm curious what your
plan is here
because if you take on e3 with check
i'll go k2 if queen e4 i have this move
i'm not exactly sure you're doing
yourself a service here because we're
reducing material by quite a bit and
getting much closer to a fortress
so i'm not so sure that e3 is actually
the idea you're looking for
keep in mind guys the more pawns you
trade the closer you get to a fortress
position
do engines believe in fortresses engines
have a lot of trouble with fortresses uh
more than human beings which is kind of
hysterical honestly
um there are certain positions where a
human can assess it as a draw much
faster than a computer can
so i see a lot of you suggested h4 which
i do believe
was played in the game and is an
excellent move but what is his idea
after
g takes h4 that is the key that you guys
have to figure out
so you've already exposed the king a
little bit why why would he sack this
pawn right
remember the ideas i've talked about
so queen h3 is interesting i'm kind of
curious how this would go queen h3
the only thing is i'm not sure you
actually have a threat like is taking is
e3 a threat i think i could still take
that
um kind of curious
like i wonder what happens if i just
play something obnoxious like here
you could play e3 but again i don't know
that you have a threat and oh i have
this
no i don't have that sorry um what can i
do here actually because the problem is
you're you're just trading too many
things right as long as you don't win my
rook by force
like after takes takes like
you better have a way to win my rook by
force here because otherwise you're just
giving away all your pawns right
so i don't see it though you you if you
take then i go here and i have this
block again right
if you play here i go here i don't see
it
maybe you do have a way to win my rook
by force right but i just don't
you can play this check but i think i
can go
back right and you haven't actually
achieved anything
uh and otherwise you don't have any
checks so if again if
i get to safety you could take this pawn
but then maybe i just go here again and
put my bishop here and again
even though you have a past pawn you're
gonna find winning this to be near
impossible
because i just
materials too reduced right like there
are so many positions where i can just
create a fortress against the one pawn
so i would say that this is not the best
approach as far as trying to win
the queen h3 is definitely a very scary
looking move so i can see why you guys
are enticed by it
but i would say that because the bishop
controls this square you're not really
doing that much with the move
aha so we have a suggestion for f5 this
is indeed the correct move
so the idea of f5 of course is that we
want to push our pawns
so let's say white black plays white
plays something like this
now we play queen g7 check for instance
queen f6 and we continue pushing and
this position is just
almost impossible uh for white to try to
defend for example let's say they play
rook g5 trying to defend some squares
this is very reasonable how do we win
now
yeah i don't know the niche drawing
thing almost is outdated at this point i
mean
he definitely i would say like if
anything he has somewhat safe tendencies
sometimes but it's like
i don't know i feel like there are other
players who are almost more drawers than
him and
i don't know but he is a good defender
if that's what you mean like he's an
excellent defender so
uh to beat to be able to outplay him and
break his defenses is not an easy thing
it seems like napoleon does very well
against him though
so a lot of you guys are suggesting f3
that's a nice move
but the question is how do you finish
the game so for example let's say i play
king ju1
what do you do now
queen f4 i see a lot of suggestions for
so queen f4
maybe this works as well because you
don't necessarily these pawns are just
so powerful
that probably you can just do this and
try to take the pawn i kind of like this
move
queen a1 i think is actually also quite
strong
uh because if if rook here you could
simply take this guy go back like
you like there's just no way to stop all
these threats i think this
i think after here this move is also
quite strong trying to come in here you
just have so many possible threats
and if the king goes here you have a
nice little combination as well
so you're talking about e3 versus after
usually you get the pawn here these two
pawns are just so powerful
e3 i think actually does the job and
then it takes here
that's good enough because you're not
going to be able to create a fortress
with pawns like this
so for example let's say you do this and
here
you can actually just grab this bishop
if you want
because the fact is that these pawns are
not good fortress pawn so fortress pawn
would be like here with a rook here
a pawn up here is almost impossible to
create a fortress with
so here you could just slowly connect
all the pawns the fact that you have
many pawns is almost irrelevant here
so i'm not saying this is a completely
trivial win of course you have to know
how to win queen versus rook you don't
have to you don't have to know how to
collect the puns
but it's a relatively easy task from
here on
um you could also play queen check first
with the idea that this check is always
available if you move the king so you
have to pin yourself
and then e3 is maybe even stronger you
can also just improve a king you have so
many options here
um in any case anish probably saw this
and saw it was bad for him
so he decided to try for a different
type of fortress he took this pawn
which at first just looks like a blunder
you play queenie one check and you take
this bishop
but the fact is this position is
incredibly close
to a draw it isn't but it's incredibly
close
and it's amazing that not only did he
aim for this clearly
kind of knowing it wasn't a draw but
that he knew exactly how to play it
and he didn't spoil the draw once
so there's one also piece of very
significant piece of endgame knowledge
here
which you should know and by the way
this is extremely close to a draw when i
say extremely i mean extremely
for example white can win this last pawn
by taking here
and black has only one way to win this
position
if the rook is on g3 here absolutely it
would be a draw
uh not not with the pawn on e4 uh but
we'll get to that later
queen d5 very good
so the key with this move is there's no
king here because of here so you're
forced to move f3
with the pawn on f2 and rook here it's
just a draw pawn and f3 rookie four it
looks like a draw right you have this
but this is actually a win but it is not
trivial
this i almost would have tried this if i
were him because i think that winning
this at least takes a fair amount of
finesse
so to give you an idea queen takes
king goes to g1 so if the king tries to
go up the board
it actually makes life harder for white
um
because all you have to do is kind of
get around so for example after this
the rook just doesn't have that many
moves and the idea of black here just to
show you
just to illustrate is you're trying to
get behind
the king once you get behind now here
you actually have to be careful because
of these checks let me give you a better
example let's say you play queen d2
first
ricka for check king e5 rookie for check
king d5
and here white just struggles for moves
if you go here i go here if you play
here i'll just collect the pawn and do
it all over again
it doesn't really matter and after here
the idea is you play queen e2
queen f1 queen g1 and then basically
your idea is you basically get the king
in front of the pawn and then
white struggles to find moves and
eventually you'll
again grab this pawn eventually this
pawn will fall if the king gets behind
it becomes easy
so this is one of those things like if
you try this i just do go here
and again i'm just going to be able to
pick off this pawn pick off this pawn
and then i have to win queen versus rook
so this is kind of the idea however
how do you crack the fortress if i bring
my king back
and i was amazed like i knew that this
was a technical win
um but i analyzed this by myself i
analyzed this with ray robson i analyzed
it with other people it was almost
impossible
to find the winning idea by ourselves it
was really really difficult
so this position i'm gonna show you the
problem and then i'm gonna see if you
guys
can figure out how to win
so white plays king of one so one of the
things is that if you play here this is
a way to win because you go here
and now you have issues with this pawn
right so you can't allow that the key is
that you either have to have a rook here
guarding the square
or you have to have a king guarding it
so for example here
you have to try this queen here
rook g4 so once again you cannot allow
this and this
right so if you allow this the king goes
here here the king goes up
and then queen f1 you go behind the
again and once you're behind this pawn
the wind becomes easier
but the question is how do you win in
this position
and this is surprisingly difficult so
i'm gonna give you guys a crack at it
how do you win this position
even queen versus rook is not the most
trivial thing in the world
but how do you win here and i'm gonna
need a line or
a particular idea right one move is not
gonna do it
with white to move would be quite
helpful yes
although even with white to move i can
go here right
because my rook covers so what do you do
uh but keep in mind i'm not gonna play
rook g5 ever i'm just gonna keep my rook
here i'm never playing rook g5
not on your life so what are you gonna
do and yeah queen h3 i play king back to
f2
not so easy
you
okay so you're i'm seeing suggestions
like this but you're kind of assuming
your opponent doesn't play chess right
like they're gonna stop you you're not
gonna be able to do this by force
you can try to check and come around
this way but it's going to be the same
thing
i'm going to come here i'm going to stop
you from doing this idea
so how do you win
i think it's just impossible i mean it's
really hard to find
uh ray and i were struggling with this
for quite a long time
but imagine if they had played this i'm
curious if nepo would have easily
cracked this or not i mean nippo may be
one
the thing is i'd say most gm's have the
knowledge that the pawn here and rook
here
is something that should be winning but
to actually do it is really really
difficult
the problem with triangulation here is i
can still kind of do this right
i don't remember how much time but
knowing nippo he had lots of time
he always plays super fast even when the
game's crazy
yeah this is quite a bit harder than
bishop and knight checkmate that is for
sure
well king to g6 though how are you
actually doing this
and this pawn is almost irrelevant
honestly like it's not
it doesn't really matter for the
position because if ever h5 you just go
and take the paw and then you come back
like it really just doesn't matter
as far as evaluation of the position
goes
all right first of all this is not a3
this is h3 guys
uh but yeah queen h3 i just come here
you're not really doing anything
so one of the key ideas here believe it
or not is that this king is actually on
a bad square
let me illustrate what i mean um
let us say i play something like this
um let me see
uh look let me go which one of the lines
i i i wrote down a few here
okay i don't know this is something else
[Music]
ah yeah h5 so let's just say they they
give away this pawn
and you come back to this position so to
give you an example right let's say they
play queen here
this is actually a really good example
so this position
looks like a zugzwang right
and the reason being that if you try
rook here you simply play queen here and
go this way
if i play
rook g4 yeah if you play rook g4 you
come this way
if you go king back you go here
and again you force yourself behind the
pawn which you know is winning
um
so but white has a resource here which
is to play here
which looks crazy right but the idea is
that if queen g5 check for instance and
rook king here you can always
give this check so as long as you hang
on to the pawn you can go back there and
then go back
so i can do this i can give a check here
but believe it or not you're making no
progress i can always go back
so the winning method here
is to give you an idea in this position
right
so in this position the way you win
is you maneuver your king
all the way over here which looks insane
right
but the idea is that you play king c5
and somehow white has no moves
if they come here you bring the king
this way that's already really bad news
if you go here i come there and now if
you go here
i simply bring the king up so the
difference is with the king on f5 it
looks like a better king but it's
actually worse
because if you go back i can't come up
so you actually need the king out of the
way
so that now the rook has nowhere to go
if here you go here
and if the king goes back for example
you give checks
come here come behind
and then you approach and now it becomes
very trivial
at least relatively right so you see how
that all worked
so getting behind the pawn is winning so
let me just show you so once you get
behind the pawn it just becomes
impossible to kind of defend
so for example if i go here you do them
here
and there's just you're going to run out
of moves if you try to move up the board
i go here
and notice how you can't push because
i'm just going to check and win your
rook
so you have to just give away your pawn
so that's why and again you have to
still win queen versus rook
of course which is its own thing uh but
that's kind of why this is winning let's
say you give a check
right i go behind your pawn and again
you just don't really have a good course
of action here
if you push up i just come behind your
pawn and your pawn can't advance without
giving away your rook
so once the queen gets behind everything
just falls apart for away
and that's kind of the key here
learning to win queen versus rook is not
easy guys and that's something you got
to learn but i'm more
i'm not so much illustrating like i'm
just showing how complex first of all
end games can be
like this game game was so complicated
but also the concept of a fortress
and how to crack it so white's idea is
basically that i'm moving my rook back
and forth you can't do anything about it
but the fact is
if you can make it so your opponent has
no good move
that's how you crack it so this is an
example of one of those positions
you play king c5 a surprising move and
all of a sudden
there's just nothing if you go up then
you come back
and then all of a sudden you're you're
king's stuck again you're in zugzwang
again
if the kid goes back then you come here
if the rook goes here you come this way
and somehow there's just no way
there's just no good move for white
so it's just a really crazy situation
in the game however he played rook g5
and now queen a1 queen b1
and he made this look so easy but the
fact is this position
is anything but easy to give you an
example
after move king f1 believe it or not
black has an only move here
at least i'm fairly sure yeah black only
has one move
and the key is you not only have to
figure out no this is not a draw this is
a win
but only with one move here is black
every other move draws
so the question is what is that move for
black
so keep in mind this is another one of
those positions where you have an
irrelevant pawn this pawn on h4 is not
super relevant it's actually annoying
but once you like this pawn is not going
anywhere right
so the key point is these two pawns and
what you have to accomplish
if you play queen c vortech for example
i play king here and how do you win
my plan is to do this until the end of
time
how do you win
and this is the key to discovering a
fortress you ask yourself do i have a
winning plan
believe it or not the answer there is no
you can even take away this pawn it
doesn't matter
how do you win
you need to provoke f3 but how do you
stop i'm just going to move my rook back
and forth
now you can try something like this
right say i go here
and then you go here you're like
twiddling your thumbs like i'm not
trying to do anything pretend this
pawn's off the board this pawn's not
relevant
now you're threatening to take the rook
again pretending this pawn is off the
board
but i'm going to go here i'm not going
to let you take that rook
uh oh sorry sorry sorry sorry this is
actually a bad this is actually a bad
move again pretend
i'm just going to make this easier for
you guys uh we're going to do this i'm
going to go and take this pawn
just for fun and now we're going to come
back and i'm going to come here
so this is an important position this
move actually does loose
i just want to make it easier for you
guys by eliminating that guy so this
move does lose how does this move loose
didn't mean to confuse you guys but
again these positions are complicated
like
i have to make sure i know all the ins
and outs myself right
quee take c3 know your king and pawn on
games right
i move over here and this is a known win
because
even though you get opposition i'm on
the sixth rank
or the third in this case so it doesn't
matter i just move to the side
and this is a fairly simple win um
however what happens if i go here
how do you win
you can wait for my rook but i just go
back and forth i just wait
if you ever try here i can just take it
that's no problem
if the queen ever goes here i can also
take it and come up this way
almost always
you'd love to trade the pawns right but
you can't every time you take your push
i just take
so believe it or not with the king here
this is a draw
so in this position after king f1 the
only move
is queen d2
so this is something that seems like
computer-ish it seems impossible
but the only way you can figure stuff
like this out
is if you figure out the concept you
have to figure out what is
what is the idea and the fact is that
with the king on e1 and rook on e3
you cannot win this position once you
realize that once you understand that
concept
play becomes easier because you have a
purpose you're not just randomly moving
your queen around
you're trying to do it with a very
specific purpose and once the queen
keeps the king cut off
you can win but even here it takes a bit
of delicacy
for example after rook h3 this happened
in the game queen d5
notice how he keeps the king cut off he
says no no queen check
queen h5 again not allowing a win if
king f1 you have queen d1 check
he's making sure that the king never
gets to e1
so rook a3 was played queen d5 again
no no king f6
and here they fiddled around a little
bit
so he lost the tempo brought his king
back and this was actually really cool
he just brings his king to f6
and here it's almost a mini zooxan
because the rook can't move
uh if the rook moves to the side then
you play like this and
are able to take the pawn because the
pawn's not irrelevant
in that like you don't you still have to
take the thing the only annoying thing
about this pawn is you have to take the
thing without allowing the king over
here
that's kind of the crucial thing right
so
you want to actually take that pawn with
the king so if the rook moves up here
then you can start doing moves like
queen f3 and e3 and you just end the
game
if you go here of course then this move
right so you must move the rook and then
the king comes over
and now you just run out of moves takes
brings the king over
the question is what is the final
winning idea i still have this why is
the king on g2 so important and this is
my final question for you guys why is
that king
so important here
if the king were here the queen were
here this is a draw you guys know this
now why is it so
important that the king is on g2 very
nice
and this fiddly was the move he resigned
because now you're threatening to take
if they take the queen you take with the
pot of course king f1
king c3 threatening this if king here
king here
so the queen can't be captured but it's
not just a fancy move like what if i
play a move like this what is my plan
after rook g3
because keep in mind if you take the
rook and i take back you're not doing
anything
but what is your plan queen here serves
a very specific purpose
but how do you trade pawns if here i
take right if here i take
i take here you're not winning anything
fancy moves are fun but
but how did you break the fortress why
did he resign why is rook g3 not a move
queen e2 is possible queenie 2 might
actually do the trick
but after queenie 2 you still need work
to do right i still go here
life still continues right
what is your plan and this is what you
have to ask yourself when cracking
fortresses you need a plan
your plan is to get the king past this
barrier
the reason why you can't win is because
the king is on this barrier
that the king cannot cross you cross the
barrier
now this is always a thing
so let's say white just keeps the rook
here right
now you come closer you have to be
careful this doesn't work by the way
guys
but you're too fast of course
and not next you're gonna come here
and now the win is easy just please do
not fall for this
that's the only thing i beg of you and
now you have to lose
don't do it this way but of course you
can just take the rook
that's the end or you could do it any
number of ways you just control this
square try to come here i mean
now it's actually very easy to win this
pawn is just too much of a weakness
right
but notice how the whole purpose of all
this maneuvering
and keeping the king out of here because
notice if you have the king here
queen here you can just take it because
the king can blockade your pawn
so the whole purpose of this was to that
you you create a blockade of this
barrier that the king can then cross
and that's the whole purpose of this
hell end game
and that's what nippo did that's why he
had to keep the king out of e1
that's why he had to maneuver the king
over here to take this pawn slowly and
then come back
and he did all this perfectly with no
issues at all so it's really really a
cool thing that he was able to do this
and that he was able to accomplish this
without ever blowing the wind
so just overall really really cool
thanks davina i'm glad you guys liked it
uh
in any case i hope you guys enjoyed the
lecture again it was a really
complicated game really complex
but i hope you guys at least got
something from it
and uh stay tuned i don't know if
there's anything coming next
uh today but definitely i'll be at the
club doing
twitch streams more lectures stuff like
that
yeah netpost pretty awesome anyway uh
anyway guys i'm glad you enjoyed it
and uh i will see you next time